hey guys driven here from how to beat  anime we're checking through all of your  comments let's go and also albert and  dom is here  oh that's right yeah they're here too  say hello they're probably popping up  here somewhere there they are  we're on top and below you i think maybe  i'm always below you griffin  that's you're a bottom person though  i i prefer  i'm i'm good with my arrangement  some comments let's go let's see two  extras six days ago i think it was good  to  see a how to be the diary god in future  diary  457 likes  god damn god damn  uh it's me right now i think it's one of  those classic niche  we're we're gonna do it it's just that  we have so much stuff that we're  preparing to do yeah it's on the  bookstore it's on the books  let's see if you to see it subscribe to  the channel